hi my name is zambi zambi mate
and i'm the founder of django makers
limited our first
product lineup heavens which are used
for sidewalks food parts and driveways
and hours we produce using recycled with
plastic
a bunch of me and friends of mine came
together and we were just tired
the government is not doing enough the
stakeholders are not doing enough we as
a people we are not doing enough so i
started by collecting plastic waste
within our estate sorting them
and selling to recyclers we realized we
are collecting more plastic
than we are selling to recyclers so that
made us think so what more can we
do so we decided why don't we start
making papers because i was a
first of all an easy entry to the market
and also the demand was high
we started in my mom's backyard and my
neighbors didn't like
the process
that's when we moved to the industrial
part of nairobi
and in 2020 we launched the product
officially in the market
let's turn trash into cash we land on
the job
the more we did the more we learned the
more we did the more learn so and we
hence become the masters of our own
skill
you have you have a project if you have
an idea if you have a solution that you
feel that you can execute you can
you you can solve that problem just
start because the fear
the feel of the unknown tends to hold
you back in starting but
once you start it's home and dry
so yeah that's me so hopefully